thanks to surf shark for helping support
this episode
hey crazies dark matter is 84 of the
matter in the universe and it
single-handedly explains a lot of stuff
gravitational lensing cluster motion
galactic rotation
fluctuations in the cmb
scientific consensus is that dark matter
exists we have piles of irrefutable
evidence
let's go through it shall we
[Music]
the first hint of dark matter came to us
all the way back in the 1930s
to the timeline
in 1933 fritz zwicky was studying a few
galaxies in the coma cluster
that's a cluster of over a thousand
galaxies about 330 million light years
away
zwicky discovered galaxies in the
cluster were moving way too fast
they were moving so fast there wasn't
enough mass to hold the cluster together
oh hey man long time no see where's
question clone i thought i could use a
break plus this video has my name
written all over it like literally okay
sure that that makes sense yep so how'd
this wiki guy take all these
measurements anyway oh oh
great question
taking measurements at cosmic scales is
tricky today let alone in 1933.
first you have to measure that distance
with some kind of standard candle
that's a star with a predictable
brightness like a cepheid variable or a
type 1a supernova
if we know the actual brightness we can
compare that to the apparent brightness
since light obeys the inverse square law
we can get a distance from that
knowing that distance gives us a sense
of size in images like this
next pull out your pocket hertzsprung
russell diagram
what
you don't have a pocket hr diagram
every respectable astrophysicist has one
of these on hand at all times
is it too starky no it's perfect okay
that's not good enough whatever you can
use mine
an hr diagram tells us almost everything
we need to know about stars if we know
its actual brightness and its color
this diagram tells us its radius and the
stage of life it's in and ultimately its
mass
this diagram is kind of a big deal and
not like big deal clone like an actual
big deal
dude again not cool
anyway this diagram was around decades
before zwiki entered the astronomy scene
all he needed was the overall brightness
of a galaxy and he could estimate the
mass of its stars
speed is a bit more difficult
cosmic distances are vast so we don't
actually see any of this stuff moving
visuals you might have seen of galaxies
colliding are simulations in extreme
fast forward
to figure out speed we need to measure
something called doppler redshift
that's when light changes frequency as
it moves toward or away from us kind of
like this
these two stars are always emitting
white light it's the relative motion
between us and them that changes the
color
blue for tortoise and red for away from
us
that's highly exaggerated though
you wouldn't be able to see the color
shift with your eyes
you have to split the light into its
spectral colors then you look for gaps
and compare those gaps to where we
expect them to be based on what the
stars are made of
it's not easy but it's something we can
do
okay let me get this straight you get
the mass from the brightness and the
speed from the redshift yep
now what now we apply gravity and see
what happens
this was originally about zwicky's
observations of a few galaxies in the
coma cluster galaxies in a cluster are
moving purely under the influence of
gravity
gravity is in control
solving a many body problem can be
tricky though so zwicky
tricky's wiki
trickies wiki used a mathematical tool
called the viral theorem
sparing you the gruesome details it
relates the kinetic and potential energy
in a system and gives us this
based on the measured speed of the
galaxy and the effective radius of the
cluster we can figure out how much mass
is needed to make the galaxy do that
spoiler alert the measured mass wasn't
enough
tricky's wiki inferred there must be
matter there that couldn't be seen there
must be some kind of dark matter
now i say inferred rather than
discovered because he had entirely the
wrong impression and his estimates were
way off
by dark matter zwicky meant matter that
is dark
essentially stuff that doesn't emit or
reflect enough light to be seen from
earth
sure that could be weird stuff but a lot
of ordinary things meet that definition
too
planets moons asteroids comets big dark
clouds or even aliens if they exist
zwicky was imagining giant clouds of
cold diffuse gas
the mass in his universe looked like
this
a tiny bit of it was stars and the rest
was mostly just gas
he had opponents and for good reason he
was making claims he didn't have enough
evidence for
that's bad science
zwicky had the right idea but for the
wrong reasons
he thought the proportions were like
this when they were actually like this
but we wouldn't figure that out for a
few more decades
back to the timeline
in 1951 harold eowyn and edwin purcell
purcell
in 1951 harold ewan and edward purcell
discovered the 21 centimeter hydrogen
line
this allowed us to find all the cold
hydrogen between stars and between
galaxies
wait wait wait wait
coal hydrogen
21 centimeter line explain this stuff
okay okay fine
you know how electrons can emit light
when they jump energy levels
well sometimes they can emit light just
by flipping over
seriously it's a thing it's called a
hyperfine transition
the electron in a hydrogen atom has
slightly more energy in one orientation
than the other
the difference is so tiny that the
transition only emits a radio photon
the wavelength of that photon 21
centimeters
even if hydrogen is cold in a diffuse
cloud of gas it'll still emit this 21
centimeter light which means we can see
it
and we see a lot of it but it still
isn't enough to explain tricky's wiki's
mass problem
then in 1962 we discovered the first
extrasolar x-ray source using detectors
on rockets
yeah you heard me rockets
earth's atmosphere absorbs a lot of
x-rays from space
x-rays from space
so our x-ray detectors have to be almost
in space before they'll see it
these days though we have space probes
orbiting the earth
anyway x-ray astronomy opened a whole
new way for us to look at our universe
and when we did we saw something new
hot hydrogen
so in the 50s we found cold hydrogen and
in the 60s we found hot hydrogen
that kind of sounds like all the
hydrogen
and it still wasn't enough to explain
the mass problem
progress on the dark matter problem
wouldn't arrive until the early 1970s
that's when vera rubin was studying
galactic rotation using kent ford's
spectrograph
vera rubin was a big deal you should
know her name
anyway she mapped out the distribution
of hydrogen in several galaxies
but when she compared that to the
rotation rates she noticed something
strange
see a galaxy isn't a solid thing the
material doesn't all rotate together
it's a bunch of separate gravitational
orbits
consider our own milky way galaxy
our sun is about this far out and orbits
around the galaxy
you might think that orbit is controlled
by the supermassive black hole at the
center but that's only partially true
the mass in control of the sun's orbit
is actually all the mass inside this
sphere
that's everything from the center out to
the orbit
if the orbit were closer the sphere
would be smaller the opposite is true
farther out
that's just how gravity works in this
kind of situation which brings us back
to vera rubin
her maps of hydrogen in a sample of
galaxies looked like this
it consistently gets thinner near the
outer edge
because of the way gravity works she
expected to see a similar drop in the
orbital speeds of stars near the outer
edge
but the data showed something else
entirely the speeds actually level off
instead of a galaxy rotating like this
it was rotating like this
when data doesn't match your prediction
it's time to reevaluate things
and that's exactly what vera rubin did
she asked herself a question
what if there's more mass than we can
see
yes this should sound familiar she's
talking about dark matter
it was the same argument tricky zwicky
made back in the 1930s but vera rubin
was doing it with a proper amount of
evidence
vera rubin was doing good science
vera rubin discovered dark matter
this was the first time that dark matter
was a legit scientific conversation
so let's take an updated look at the
breakdown for matter
active stars represent about 1.5 percent
of the matter in the universe
planets moons asteroids comets and
aliens
.005 percent
altogether
not even worth counting
diffuse clouds of gas and dust 14.5
there's still 84
unaccounted for
that's the stuff we call dark matter
but you know what maybe you're still not
convinced
maybe the motion of galaxies and
clusters and the orbits of stars and
galaxies aren't enough for you well i've
got more evidence for you
back to the timeline
in 1979 we discovered the first
gravitationally lensed object
that's when light from a distant object
is bent around another and we see
multiple images
mass bends space-time and anything
traveling through that space-time will
be affected by any bends there might be
in it that includes light
this lensing effect usually occurs
around bright massive galaxies
but occasionally we find gravitational
lensing around seemingly empty space
in 1998 we discovered the bullet cluster
that's two clusters of galaxies that
have collided
collided might be a strong word they
kind of just pass through each other but
you get the idea
observing with visible light this pair
of clusters isn't much to look at most
of the light being emitted is actually
x-rays
remember that's the hot hydrogen we
started finding in the 1960s
anyway these two pink blobs are what we
actually see with x-ray telescopes
this one on the right gives the bullet
cluster its name
but if you look closer you'll see
gravitational lensing over here
despite there not being enough mass in
that spot for the lensing to occur
the vast majority of the visible mass is
in the pink blobs
the gravitational lensing is caused by
invisible matter
by dark matter
isn't dark matter supposed to be in
galaxies what's it doing all the way
over there the collision separated the
regular matter from the dark matter
before the clusters collided all the
matter was mixed together as expected
but as the collision occurs the regular
matter interacts and slows down
dark matter doesn't interact in the same
way it doesn't slow down
this allows the dark matter to get out
ahead of the regular matter in the
collision
it separates them
but if you're still not convinced let's
take a look at this cosmologically
the cosmic microwave background or cmb
is arguably the greatest source of data
we have available about our universe
it's the oldest light that currently
exists
so what direction is it coming from all
directions
this is just a map of the spherical sky
using the mall vita projection you've
seen maps of earth using the same
projection
just like the earth the cmb is actually
a sphere
so this is what the cmb looks like it's
mostly uniform but we can see tiny
variations if we exaggerate them for
clarity
those variations tell us a crapton about
our universe
here's the 2018 data from the planck
space probe
but just throwing the data at you like
that isn't exactly user friendly we can
do better
starting with the standard model of
cosmology known as lambda cdm
that's dark energy plus cold dark matter
we can plot out exactly what we expect
those background variations to look like
that would be something like this
the first peak assumes a universe with
zero curvature
the second peak assumes all the regular
matter that we observe that's all the
stars and all the diffuse gas
the third peak assumes the rest of the
matter is dark matter
so this is what the model would predict
for an 84
dark matter universe
the measured data from the actual cmb
tells us this
it matches perfectly with the prediction
including the dark matter peak
bingo bango
huh
that's kind of undeniable isn't it yep
pretty much
also this is just the highlights i'm
holding back here because this video is
already too long
the point is we have almost a century of
evidence backing this up it's not just
some random idea
and every time we collect more data it
just supports the existence of dark
matter when it was just the weird motion
of galaxies we couldn't take it
seriously
dark matter wouldn't be taken seriously
until vera rubin's measurements of
galactic rotation
then we discovered gravitational lensing
around seemingly empty regions of space
the data from the cosmic microwave
background is just the most recent item
on the pile
dark matter exists
the data is irrefutable consensus has
been reached
and scientists are pretty argumentative
amongst each other if they reach
consensus it's a big deal and you should
take it seriously
and you should also take your online
purchases seriously
today's sponsor surfshark can help with
that
surf shark is a vpn or virtual private
network which masks your location by
routing you through servers in other
countries
why is this helpful to the average
person well there's this thing called
price discrimination
that's when an online store or service
decides its price
based on your previous browsing habits
and on how affluent your location is
have you ever been planning a vacation
but decided to sleep on it only to find
the price had gone up the next day
it didn't actually go up they just know
you made the same search yesterday that
price hike is designed to make you panic
and purchase now
surf shark can hide your habits and
switch your location to get you the best
price on hotels flights car rentals and
many other online purchases
you can also use surfshark on an
unlimited number of devices so it
doesn't matter if you're planning your
vacation on your computer or your phone
if you're interested go to the link in
the description and enter promo code
asylum
you'll get 83 off and three extra months
for free which is a good deal
it'll also let surf shark know you heard
about them from me which helps out the
channel
so which piece of evidence do you find
the most compelling for dark matter
please share in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to my patreon
patrons and youtube members like sean k
for making it possible for this to be my
job
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
eric totally expected me to get electro
boomed by my crazy circuit board
that board is pretty dangerous isn't it
all that exposed metal on 120 volts ac
please don't ever do anything like that
at home i'm a trained professional
i've been shocked by this thing a few
times but i'm still alive because i know
what i'm doing anyway thanks for
watching